have a look at this one number two so
what kind of shape is this again such a
nappy it's a parabola okay so um what to
like about this is it's got a great nice
simple smooth curve to it I have the
vertex right there however I won't point
out there's just one piece information
that's missing because at the moment
when I look at that that could be minus
x squared or it could be minus 2 x
squared or minus 3 x squared they they
all look like that so I need to put on
one more piece of information that helps
me know it's this one and not some other
graph what piece of information do I
need anything I need to know
horizontally vertically how big is this
thing right like a point like say here
if that was x equals 1 is the y-value
like is that a really small number is a
like a negative 1/2 or negative 1/4 or
is it a huge number is it negative 100
because remember those actually can have
different scales right so I kind of need
to know where that is how do I find out
where that is how do I find out the Y
value if I know the x value which is 1
what I do I'm going to substitute in
right so if X is equal to 1 then Y will
be equal to watch carefully right minus
1 squared I'm taking that number and I'm
popping it into the original equation
that defies this whole situation okay so
what is Y then Y will be just minus 1
watch out that negative sign is not
being squared how would I write this if
I did what's the negative sign to be
squared I need some brackets around that
but there aren't records so the minus
sign is separate to the square root okay
so therefore this point here is 1
negative 1 and you shall have a point
like that on your graph 2 it doesn't
have to be that point it could be any
other point so this is a point that
shows me how big missing use okay I
guess we'll shuffle over to number 4
I'll have a look at this power here
what's this guy
Corian it's a cubic curve the shape
looks great I noticed we have the
y-intercept there zero one thumbs up we
need the x-intercept though how do I
find out the x-intercept so find the
y-intercept you make X 0 to find the x
intercepts you make y 0 okay so we can
actually let's drop this down just over
here if Y is 0 then X cubed plus 1 is
equal to 0 do you see I've just put 0
where Y was so you can see I can solve
this by rearranging it just a teeny bit
huh what's the number but when you
multiply it by itself three times gives
you negative 1 negative 1 and you can
check that into your calculator as well
I'm you can use the cube root button
you've got a cube root button there okay
so therefore that the x-intercepts
that's the value I need to put in over
here negative 1 okay this cubic curve is
missing some things on the ends what
does it need on the end
it needs arrows why does it mean arrows
yeah it shows that it never stops some
graphs actually stop they have a
beginning they have an end this graph
keeps going forever okay so those arrows
mean do I need a point for scale on this
one if you're not sure if you're ever
unsure just just put it on because that
way you can be safe okay however in this
case I know how big this thing is
because I have a wine set and exited
I've got both okay in this case do you
see I only had that one point of
information so I didn't know how big
this thing was
but when I've got two I'm happy okay all
right let's have a look at the ones that
we haven't got yet this guy over here
what kind of shape is it it's not a
parabola it's not a cubic curve it's a
straight line that's why we record a
linear function see this number are half
what does that tell you about the graph
it tells you both toes of the gradient
so if the gradient is 1/2 how would you
describe that in words like is that up
down steep shallow what is
it's shallow it's less than 1 is it
going up we're just going down it's
going up because it's positive isn't it
right so there's a plus sign hydrogen so
therefore I know that it's going to sort
of draw up like that
what is it plus to tell me it's how high
it is right so it's the y-intercept so
there's two so now I'm going to throw it
in there you go
now just like always I need some
intercept you already told me what the
widest it is it's - how do I find the
x-intercept
I'm it just like before I make y equals
zero when you put zero here if you go
ahead and you solve I think you should
get X is equal to negative four
beautiful and one of the great things
that having drawn your graph is that if
you draw it reasonably you guys even
have a grid on your page it even sort of
looks like negative 4 do you notice that
like it's this further way it's on the
left-hand side so negative 4 confirms
these for us I do want to point out when
I was going around I had a look
several people drew their side axes but
then their set of axis was too small and
they only saw like that much of the
graph so I don't know whether the other
intercept is and that's kind of
important so you need to make sure your
graph is big enough your Cartesian plane
is big enough so you can see everything
ok before I do this last one can I just
point a tension Markham in a picture
book
look at there we go
so yeah freeze it when your armies are
providing the way that's great okay
yeah I just want to point two marks
before we look at the last one so we had
a look at this you can see it's got that
that slope there throughout the points
we mentioned when you have a look at his
parabola I really like please pay close
attention to this shape one of the
things that's important about it is you
notice it gets steeper and steeper and
steeper but it never actually goes like
straight up and down and it certainly
never like sort of comes back on itself
I had a look around I saw some people's
who sort of whips back around because
you sort of you draw the curve and
that's what your hand does if it does
that by accident you have it extra bit
here just just rub it out let you grasp
it in pencil right like what is so
therefore that's easy to fix
last one I'll make this one quick this
is the start of an H what kind of shape
is it
it's the hyperbola so it's got the funny
dotted lines on it these are the
asymptotes because the graph approaches
the lines that never quite gets there
okay this is the general shape you're
expecting it never collides in any of
the axes so there are no intercepts to
find that's kind of nice less work but
it does mean I need one of these guys
right because I've got no idea if this
is 2 over X or 1 over X or 500 over X so
what point would you like me to put on
there give me an x value how about x
equals 1 x equals 1 is always a really
easy number to play with because it's so
easy to calculate so if I just say that
point there let's call that one
what will y equal 2 over 1 is just 2
so I label that smart and I say 1 comma
2 ok
and it's really nice you might have
noticed I drew it before I knew where
that was you're like that - doesn't look
twice as high as that one is to the
right but it doesn't matter the
excellent wires can be completely
independent so you can draw your shape
and then just label it accordingly all
right